corona hat das land im griff die
menschen haben angst vor dem virus und
die regierenden sehen es nicht ungern
wenn aus dieser angst vor sicht wird die
menschen sorgen sich aber auch um ihre
zukunft oder gar um ihre existenz und
diese sorgen könnten umschlagen in
vertrauensverlust oder gar wut wer
profitiert von verunsicherungen in der
krise
die regierungsparteien die afg obwohl
sie gerade ihre vielleicht größte krise
erlebt die querdenker oder die linke wir
müssen reden mit diesen gästen georg
mascolo für den investigativen
journalisten ist klar die afg versucht
die korona proteste für sich zu nutzen
timo grub aller der bundessprecher der
afg sagt dazu querdenker zählen für uns
zum bürgertum
sahra wagenknecht die linken politikerin
sagt die korona politik ist für viele
desaströs
matthias jung von der forschungsgruppe
wahlen stellt fest die afg setzt auf die
wirtschaftlichen verlierer
und herbert reul der nrw- innenminister
saad teile der afg bewegen sich immer
mehr in eine rechtsextreme richtung
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
sie begrüßt die gäste heute abend
herzlich an diesem tisch und
zugeschaltet aus düsseldorf und mannheim
und los gehts viele menschen haben angst
vor dem corona virus manche vor einer
corona diktatur lassen wir ruhig die im
regen stehen die zu einer die nur allzu
gerne rum krakeelen und rump rollen oder
auch andere dazu einladen wie wir das
vergangene woche leider im bundestag
erleben mussten weil sie sich in der
rolle des provokateurs gefallen wie
pubertierende schuljungen es ist eine
kriegserklärung an die hälfte der
eigenen partei heute knöpft sich den
rechtsnationalen flügel vor
wer also gerne weiter revolution oder
politik kav rolle spielen will kann kann
und sollte das dann woanders tun aber
bitte nicht in der alb die dümpelnde
umfragewerte angst vor einer beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz leuten gibt
sich bürgerlich ist es wirklich klug von
einer cola diktatur zu sprechen
wir leben in keiner diktatur sonst
könnten wir diesen parteitag heute
wonach kaum so abhalten
die allianz der afg mit corona leugnen
führt unlängst zum eklat im bundestag
rechte blogger versuchen abgeordnete und
minister einzuschüchtern
auf einladung von afg abgeordneten zwar
entschuldigt sich galant später doch
erstmal heißt er auf eine cola diktatur
auf wiederum verträgt sich nicht mit
unserer freiheitlich-demokratischen es
ist die ewige suche der afg nach dem
wutbürger nach flüchtlingskrise und
klima skepsis jetzt also die pandemie
als stimmenfänger
zumindest war das der plan corona ist
krone
dabei hatte die afg beim corona ausbruch
im frühjahr noch ganz auf vorsicht
masken und lockdown gesetzt
zusammen stehen ist jetzt erste
bürgerpflicht deshalb werden wir auch
den finanziellen maßnahmen und
gesetzlichen änderungen weitgehend
zustimmen die weit überwiegende mehrheit
in unserem land geht mit der
ansteckungsgefahr sehr vernünftig und
ist zum linear dom
die menschen halten abstand voneinander
sie versammeln sich nicht warten
geduldig vor geschäften viele tragen
mundschutz
ja das war noch im märz dieses jahres
bei uns ist die lokale einer der zwei
vorsitzenden der afg seit einem jahr
sind sie an der seite von jörg nolte
wann hair group ag hat ihre partei
festgelegt dass das corona wir uns nicht
mehr gefährlich ist oder überhaupt nicht
gefährlich ist
es hat bei uns niemand festgelegt also
niemand von uns leid corona wir gehen
die maßnahmen an wir sehen wie
unverhältnismäßig die maßnahmen hier
mittlerweile wirken in der
bundesrepublik wie auch der arbeiter der
doktor der jetzt wieder beschlossen
wurde
wir sehen natürlich die risiken für die
für den mittelstand für die wirtschaft
die gastronomie und theorie und auf
diese sorgen und nöte gehen wir ein was
die bevölkerung bewegt und wenn die an
hocke die pandemie für beendet erklärt
und sagt wird auch nicht wiederkommen
dann wird er sich da ja das ist ein
interview gewesen aus dem frühsommer
glaube ich diesen jahres und august war
natürlich noch andere zahlen die dort
vorherrschten
also natürlich hat sich diese dieser
situation geändert ganz nach parteitag
auf welcher seite sind sie jetzt ja
kubala sagen sie wie helgoland wir haben
eine korrektur oder sind sie auf der
seite von jörg leuten der das gegenteil
behauptet wird dass ich bin
bundesvorsitzende gesamten partei ich
denke die gesamte partei auf ich stelle
mich vor meine mitglieder vermeiden vor
unsere mitglieder die in der partei viel
gutes arbeiten haben ein super parteitag
abgehalten jetzt in kalkar bleiben wir
ganz kurz noch mal bei der frage auf
wessen seite sie es gibt keine seite für
mich ich stehe als bundesvorsitzender
für alle seiten für alle strömungen da
bin ich offen und werde mich auch
integrative mit diesen strömung
auseinander setzen wir sind volkspartei
in ostdeutschland wollen das auch in
westdeutschland werden und deshalb werde
ich auch beide strömungen abbilden und
wäre natürlich auch mal dazu beitragen
dass die sich natürlich auch integrativ
in der partei verhalten wahnsinnig
integrativ sie haben auf dem parteitag
davon gesprochen dass man schmutzige
wäsche nicht in der öffentlichkeit
waschen soll das war noch die geringste
formulierung der kritiker
von heute diese zeige nach die ist
vorbei
lieber york dieser weg ist ein irrweg
dieser weg ist falsch du spalt ist die
parteipolitik ist vor allen dingen auch
stimmung im land die menschen die heute
auf die straße gehen sind die mutigsten
menschen in diesem jahr und professor
volk hatte sich gestern mit
hunderttausenden corona maßnahmen gegen
an verdorben
aber ich sage wir sind diejenigen die
diesen menschen draußen eine stimme
geben
eckige wäsche sollte man zu hause
waschen und nicht in der öffentlichkeit
das ist eine fundamentale kritik noch
mal die frage für welche hälfte der
partei sprechen sie heute ab ich spreche
ja gar keine helfrich für die gesamte
partei
das ist die aufgabe des
bundesvorsitzenden wir haben eine
intensive debatte gehabt auf dem
bundesparteitag am morgen hat eine sehr
polarisierende rede gehalten und
deswegen wollte auch die wie der
überwiegende teil der mitgliedschaft
diese aussprache und das haben wir
geführt und das halte ich in der
lebendigen demokratie auch lebendigen
debatte die wir als partei sind wir für
absolut notwendig und wichtig und
durchgeführt hat ihr ko-vorsitzender und
das ist er ja hat ja auch heute noch ihr
vertrauen haben ist wie ich bis nächstes
jahr als bundesvorsitzender gewählt wir
arbeiten zusammen wir werden uns
gegenseitig unterstützen das werde ich
auch in der jetzigen zeit tun sie werden
sich gegenseitig unterstützen absolut
natürlich wir sind bei georg mascolo
investigativ journalist wir haben die
bilder gerade in unserem einspielfilm
auch gezeigt demonstranten randalierend
vor dem reichstagsgebäude und auch auf
den fluren bauland sagt die sache mit
den gästen sei aus dem ruder gelaufen
ist diese zerknirschung von alexander
gauland in ihren augenklappe daran haben
jedenfalls viele parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier erhebliche zweifel die
davon überzeugt sind dass das an diesem
tag kein zufall gewesen ist es ist einen
protest vor dem reichstag und auch im
reichstag geben sollte die afd
soweit kennt man die geschichte bis
heute hat sich für die vorfälle
entschuldigt die bundestagspolizei
untersucht den vorgang ich glaube sie
tut es auf eine ganz ungewöhnliche
akribische art und weise wertet
besucher protokolle aus videoaufnahmen
die es gibt und es gibt zumindest ein
indiz dass aus meiner sicht darauf
hindeutet dass jedenfalls nicht alle in
der fraktion so unwissend gewesen sein
können wir wissen es durch recherchen
von kolleginnen und kollegen von mir
dass es mindestens eine sprachnachricht
gegeben hat von einer der schülerinnen
die wir gerade auch im bild gesehen hat
die sich vorher sehr wohl an die
fdp-fraktion gewendet hatte und gesagt
ich möchte durch filmaufnahmen machen
und ich würde gern so formuliert sie es
bilder machen von denjenigen die die
täter sind also ich bin sehr gespannt
wohin diese ermittlungen führen würden
was sucht und was findet die afg bei
diesen querdenker demonstranten ich
glaube sie sucht das was ihr auch in der
vergangenheit schon erfolge gebracht hat
den anschluss an wut und sie ist dabei
sehr wir uns gerade schon diskutiert sie
ist dabei ja auch nicht sonderlich
wählerisch ich glaube wenn man sieht was
viele der querdenker vertreten auch auf
der demonstration vertreten haben dann
ist es ja nicht nur so dass teile der
afg sich mit ihm solidarisch erklären
sondern wenn man sich einige der videos
anschaut offen angehörigen ihrer
fraktion aus dem reichstag
herausgekommen sind und reden gehalten
haben auf dieser demonstration dann
fügen sie ja den verschwörungs mythen
die ohnehin schon unterwegs sind auch
noch neue hinzu ich habe beispielsweise
von ihrem kollegen müller dieses video
gesehen in dem er sagt anfang des jahres
sei ohnehin klar gewesen dass eigentlich
das finanzsystem am zusammenbruch
gewesen sei und corona biene jetzt
letztlich dem zweck all das zu
vertuschen auch zu vertuschen dass der
zusammenbruch des papiergeldes
bevorgestanden bevorgestanden hätte also
es ist der versuch anzuschließen an alte
erfolge und sich dafür die wut die sich
auf der straße entlädt zunutze zu machen
und dabei nicht wählerisch zu sein nicht
wählerisch zu sein wir begrüßen herbert
reul in düsseldorf innenminister von
nordrhein westfalen
herr wir haben es alle verfolgt detail
lockdown geht weiter bis zum 10
januar viele menschen leiden darunter
die politik haben die regierungen zu
schnell alle die diese maßnahmen
kritisieren zu idioten erklärt ich
glaube ich nicht es war ja
unterschiedlich da hat ja der eine so
der andere so bewertet das ist nicht
ganz einfach denn natürlich gibt es bei
denen die auf die straße gehen und die
sorge haben menschen die wirklich sorge
haben die beunruhigt sind und die auch
erwarten dass politik sich kümmert und
ich finde der radon uns alle ist diesen
teil derjenigen demonstrieren auch ernst
zu nehmen aber wir beobachten natürlich
schon dass über die monate immer mehr
rechtsextreme kräfte
diese demonstration nutzen auch die wut
der leute die da ist missbrauchen für
ihre zwecke und das wächst
dieser einfluss das ist nicht zu leugnen
dass und glaube ich muss mal zur
kenntnis nehmen und man kann man man
muss sich entscheiden ob man jetzt sagt
das ist alles kein problem wurde ob man
warum vor dem was sich da entwickelt und
ich finde die politik muss waren vor dem
wasser an problemen sich entwickeln kann
gefahren besteht weil ich erwarte auch
von denen die ernsthafte sorgen haben
dass ich von den trennen
ich muss nicht jeden mitlaufen lassen in
einer demonstration sahra wagenknecht
ist bei uns frühere fraktionsvorsitzende
von die linke
frau bank nicht man hat den eindruck die
linke spielt bei diesen protesten keine
rolle warum ist es eigentlich so wenn es
vor allen dingen auch sozial
benachteiligte menschen trifft gut wir
spielen jetzt bei diesen demonstrationen
keine rolle ansonsten haben wir
natürlich sehr viele die auch bei uns
also wo wir resonanz bekommen und ich
finde es gerade ein öffentliches problem
dass man den ganzen protest sehr stark
auf die reduziert und auch in eine
richtung ja debattiert der überhaupt
nicht repräsentativ ist für die menschen
die dort auch auf die straße gehen oder
teilweise auch nicht auf die straße
gehen ich meine natürlich ist es immer
so dass die afg oder auch andere rechte
versuchen wut und unzufriedenheit zu
instrumentalisieren
aber die frage ist doch wer ist
verantwortlich dafür dass so viele leute
wütend sind das so viele leute
unzufrieden sind und das ist in dem fall
nicht die rechte nicht die fdp regiert
ja nicht
und das finde ich das kernproblem und
deswegen würde ich mir auch wünschen
auch heraus wenn sie sagen man muss
jetzt waren also man sollte doch mal
drüber nachdenken warum brechen so
vielen menschen die die warum bricht zu
vielen die soziale existenz weg und
natürlich ist es absurd wenn hier das
bild gemalt wird wir seien jetzt
ungefähr im jahr 1933 und wir hätten
jetzt hier ein ermächtigungsgesetz das
ist eine absurde theorien aber man muss
natürlich auch sagen wir haben keine
corona diktatur aber wir haben auch
keine funktionierende demokratie wir
haben eine situation wo starke
wirtschaftliche interessen gruppen viel
mehr einfluss auf die politik haben als
die mehrheit der normalen bürger und das
hat sich jetzt auch wieder bei diesen
rettungspaketen gezeigt und das dann
menschen natürlich ohnmächtig sind und
auch unter sich ohnmächtig fühlen wütend
sind dass sie das gefühl haben ihre
interessen spielen keine rolle ein
großunternehmen kriegt mehr als alle
kleinen unternehmen selbstständigen
freiberufler zusammen ja das ist doch
verständlich und da finde ich muss mal
was tun
und dagegen muss man vor allem auch
politisch einschreiten und da ist die
linke die partei die das anspricht
wir sind noch mal wir ordnen es ein
bisschen herold vielleicht zunächst bei
der frage diesem geschäft mit der angst
das unterstellt man der afg aber hat
mich auch die bundeskanzlerin die angst
vor corona in ihrem repertoire sowie die
grünen den klimaschutz in ihrem
repertoire haben
jetzt muss man nur unterschreiben wenn
man die probleme benennt und den
menschen auch sagt dass es eine
gefährliche situation ist und dass wir
uns ungeheuren bemühen müssen dann ist
das eine aufgabe der regierung mehr
macht ein grammer hat es total richtig
die andere missbrauchen ja die ängste
das ja ein ganz anderes motiv das die
nutzen ist nicht um menschen dazu zu
bringen dass es nicht klug verhalten
sondern genau im gegenteil die sagen
sehen ja angst und sagen gleichzeitig
keine masken an wurde sagt es gibt gar
kein problem nennen die die sorgen die
wir zu recht benennen müssen sind dass
wir eine pandemie haben die wirklich
gefährlich ist und die wir noch nicht im
griff haben und dafür muss man waren
übrigens gleich auch der kleine hinweis
mal die allermeisten menschen gehen
nicht auf die straße die allermeisten
menschen verhalten sich ordentlich die
allermeisten menschen machen keinen
krach die allermeisten menschen sind
sehr
künftig und verändern sie die blanken
umfragewerte der cdu betrachten könnte
man natürlich auch sagen die cdu ist ein
pandemie gewinner
ich bin im moment so komisch das klingt
glaube ich das wichtigste ist nicht
jetzt um fragen zu gucken aber es ist
natürlich oft so dass in
krisensituationen diejenigen die
regierung wenn sie es ordentlich machen
das vertrauen der menschen auch haben
aber das für mich jetzt nicht die frage
ist wie wir sind noch weit weg wie
gespalten ist dieses land wie sehr wird
auch rücksicht genommen und wird bedacht
dass menschen tatsächlich an ihrer
existenziellen grenzen stoßen
na gut das ist es glücklicherweise ein
land ich glaube auch im europäischen und
im weltweiten vergleich in dem der staat
sich zumindestens darum bemüht die
härten abzumildern
für all diejenigen die auf eine
besondere art und weise von der pandemie
betroffen sind es ist auch absolut
notwendig weil pandemien noch nie große
gleichmacher gewesen sind und dann die
schwächsten besonders hart getroffen
haben deswegen ist das auch notwendig
ich würde aber gern zu dem was wir
gerade diskutiert haben die der frage
wer geht da eigentlich auf die straße
natürlich gehen der ganz viele hoch
vernünftige besorgte menschen auf die
straße übrigens können auch aus
verzweiflung zweifel erwachsen
ich habe übrigens auch viele
demonstrationen gesehen oder von ihnen
gelesen um menschen auf die straße gehen
und sie halten sich beispielsweise an
alle regeln abstand und maske kenne auch
viele demonstrationen wo man sich ganz
ausdrücklich darum bemüht diese regeln
einzuhalten
die schwierigkeit bei den
demonstrationen haben wir in wahrheit
nur an der stelle wo im grunde der regel
der gesetzesbruch mit der demonstration
einhergeht wo ich nur auf die straße
gehe und sage den abstand halte ich
nicht ein und die maske setze ich nicht
auf und die versammlungsfreiheit ist ein
hohes gut die ist unglücklicherweise im
märz und im april weiter eingeschränkt
gewesen als es gut gewesen ist
das hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
sehr schnell korrigiert es muss auch so
sein versammlungsfreiheit das eine was
das virus nie zum erliegen bringen wird
ist die politische diskussion in diesem
land
und das recht dagegen auf die straße zu
gehen gegen die maßnahme aber sagen wir
mal der permanente regelbruch und das
was ich mir wünschen würde nämlich dass
man sich schon überlegt mit wien gehe
ich eigentlich auf die straße
da etwas wählerischer zu sein ich glaube
wenn rechtsextremisten aufmarschieren
tunes aus meiner sicht auch ein meter
fünfzig abstand nicht da wäre ein
bisschen mehr irgendwie schon gut und
ich glaube das ist die schwierigkeit die
wir haben der bei dieser doppelte
regelbruch ansonsten sind
demonstrationen angemessen notwendig und
ob man die ziele teilt oder nicht das
gute recht eines jeden menschen in
diesem land und nun gucken wir noch mal
auf ihr argument von vorhin tatsächlich
welche beziehungen und welche bezüge gab
es auf teilen der demonstration auch zu
fd und das waren die bilder die wir
kennen dreißigste august am rande der
großen querdenker demo versuchen reichs
bürger und corona leugner den reichstag
zu stürmen
im umfeld der demonstrationen im august
und november auch immer afd abgeordnete
ohne mundschutz rangeleien mit der
polizei
andere fdp vergleichen die beschlüsse
heute mit 1933 genau so wusste man
natürlich auch im märz 1933 nicht wohin
sich das dann entwickelt haben ist man
kann es ja wohl rückschau dann im
endeffekt auch richtig beurteilen aber
der anfang ist sehr ähnlich
da ist normal hans jörg müller und wenn
wir also in einer diktatur leben dann
wird widerstand im grunde zur pflicht
das ist infam und gefährlich dieses
interview hier ist aufgenommen zehn
minuten fußmarsch vom ort an dem das
ermächtigungsgesetz verabschiedet worden
ist der groll oper nahe dem heutigen
kanzleramt 1933 beginnt eine echte
höllenfahrt für dieses land und für den
rest der welt und wie man bei allen
fehlern die beim infektionsschutzgesetz
gemacht worden sind über die wir gerne
reden können ich glaube dass die
regierung und das parlament viel zu spät
erkannt haben dass das anständige
gesetzliche grundlagen braucht im
infektionsschutzgesetz dass der sommer
im grunde so wie in anderen bereichen
auch übersehen worden ist dass es gut
gewesen wäre dieses gesetz zu
spezifizieren und in ruhe zu diskutieren
dass darin ein echter mangel liegt aber
in politischen fehlern in irrtümern in
falschen einschätzung das ist keine
diktatur und es ist kein
ermächtigungsgesetz und ich finde es
kein ermächtigungsgesetz
ermächtigungsgesetz finde ist gefährlich
und fahrlässig solche begriffe in den
mund zu nehmen
und wenn ich ihnen zuhöre vertreten sie
den teil der findet dass man nicht
gesundheitsdiktatur sagen darf und nicht
ermächtigungsgesetz aber auch den teil
der findet dass man das sagen darf und
ich glaube dass da die grenze des
sagbaren überschritten müssen
leben wir also in einer corona diktatur
oder nicht mit dem nicht in einer
diktatur wir sehen aber sicherlich
bezüge in diese richtung das zum
beispiel bestimmte berufsgruppen einem
de facto berufsverbot haben was zum
beispiel in der gastronomie alle aktuell
der fall ist wir sehen dass die und die
unverletzbarkeit der wohnung in frage
gestellt wird das mittlerweile dort die
polizei überprüfen kann im privatbereich
wie viele besucher zu gast sind ob ich
meinen kindern und wie viel mit meinen
kindern wie viele kinder dort spielen
dürfen dass die kanzlerin bestimmen
möchte mit wem und wie viel ich
weihnachten zu feiern habe und das in
freiheit und grundrechte die ich mir
nicht nehmen also ich lasse mir von
einem ministerpräsidenten und auch von
einer kanzlerin nicht vorschreiben wie
ich weihnachten zu feiern habe das lehne
ich ab und das leben wie auch als afg ab
nur ich glaube das problem ist doch dass
man die kritik die er durchaus
berechtigt ist und ich finde auch dass
das infektionsschutzgesetz ein extrem
schlechtes gesetz ist das völlig
schwammige bedingungen formuliert für
ganz erhebliche grundrechte
einschränkung ich finde das ein
richtiges problem aber diese kritik wird
natürlich diskreditiert von denen die
eine einrichtung der kritik einschlagen
die einfach nur ja sie haben es gesagt
in farm ist also die völlig überzogen
ist die völlig jenseits dessen ist was
man als vernünftiger mensch irgendwie
akzeptieren kann also wenn eben ns
vergleiche gebracht werden
denn wenn leute auf demos auftreten die
also irgendwie pausbäckig und frisch
sagen sie fühlen sich also wie sophie
scholl weil sie jetzt immer auf demos
reden und demos an anmelden wo ich sagen
muss also ich weiss nicht wenn ich deren
geschichtslehrer gewesen wäre ich hätte
irgendwie glaube ich so jetzt alle
gedanken bekommen also das ist ja völlig
absurd was er erzählt wird und das
schlimme was ich finde ist dass wir uns
viel zu sehr mit diesen absurditäten
beschäftigen statt mit der debatte
darüber ist es zum beispiel angemessen
in dieser form grundrechte
einzuschränken noch dazu jenseits
parlamentarischer beratungen also der
bundestag redet ja immer danach
vielleicht mal drüber auch die
landesparlamente es wird nichts
beschlossen
es sind jetzt tatsächlich regeln
getroffen dass sowas auf dauer auch
möglich sein wird das finde ich ein
riesiges problem und ich finde dass
diejenigen die das umtreibt die dafür
auf die straße gehen oder auch nicht auf
die straße gehen aber dies trotzdem
umtreibt das sind ja nicht so wenige
dass man die angst nehmen muss und ich
muss sagen die formulierung von herrn
rolf vorhergesagt hat als die mehrheit
der menschen verhält sich ordentlich die
geht nicht auf die straße das finde ich
schon ist ein zungenschlag den wir
leider in der debatte immer mehr haben
es kommt schon so eine diskussion auf ja
ist man dann eigentlich noch ein
ordentlicher staatsbürger wenn man jetzt
in dieser situation auf die straße gehen
also ich teile das was sie gesagt haben
natürlich muss man das einhalten was es
an regeln und gesetzen gibt aber
selbstverständlich hat man das recht auf
die straße zu gehen und
selbstverständlich ist man nicht
ordentlich auch wenn man es nicht tut
und ich finde diese ganze diskussion hat
etwas sehr bedenkliches weil sie schon
ängste instrumentalisiert ich verstehe
dass menschen angst vor krone haben
jeder hat das irgendwie aber ich finde
wir müssen auch die relationen sehen
also menschen neigen natürlich dazu die
gefahr die immer diskutiert wird sehr
groß zu bewerten und andere gefahren die
genauso da sind aber nicht in der
öffentlichkeit stehen weniger also zum
beispiel sterben in deutschland jedes
jahr zwischen 20.000 und 30.000 menschen
an krankenhauskeimen das könnte man
beheben durch eine bessere ausstattung
der krankenhäuser das sind mehr menschen
als an corona wahrscheinlich dieses jahr
sterben aber das ist eine gefahr die
nicht in der öffentlichkeit diskutiert
wird also es wurde viel zu wenig nahe
aber nicht ausreichend also nicht wie
corona also wir haben nicht jeden tag
die zahlen wie viele menschen sind jetzt
akut erkrankt wie viele menschen sind
gestorben
also es gibt viele gefahren die es gibt
und wir haben jetzt ein fokus auf eine
gefahr ganz massiv sie ist eine gefahr
kann kann das soll aber sie ist
natürlich also ich meine natürlich hat
jeder bezogen auf sich und gerade wenn
es seine ältere menschen in seinem
umfeld hat hat natürlich angst dass sie
sich mit dieser krankheit infizieren
aber trotzdem muss die frage berechtigt
sein was ist verhältnismäßig was ist
sinnvoll gegeben dass seine weise höher
zu wenig an herbert reul nach düsseldorf
herr all ist zu wenig diskutiert worden
über das was die regierung und die
ministerpräsidenten entschieden haben
und gibt es eben einen grundrechte keine
grundrechte einschränkung die man den
menschen die nur nicht genug erklärt
sondern die man eben auch zu wenig
diskutiert
das ist die frage die es nicht ganz
einfach zu beantworten denn natürlich
hätte man alles noch viel intensiver und
länger diskutieren können aber in einer
solchen krisensituation muss man auch
entscheidungen treffen und die muss man
schnell treffen den wollen nämlich
wirkung erzielen
und da ist man dann immer muss man
abwägen was man zu welchem zeitpunkt
macht ich kann ihnen sagen die letzten
wohl
hatte haben wir im politischen raum und
kabinetten aber auch im landtag
intensivst europa geredet immer wieder
darüber geredet und natürlich ist der
punkt genau der punkt team bestreitet ja
keiner die abwägung zwischen dem was man
machen muss wie weit man auch in
grundrechte eingreift und wie weit man
es nicht tut gerade wir noch westfalen
werden doch die debatte permanent als
armin laschet dann immer darauf
hingewiesen hat und gesagt hat
leute wir müssen aufpassen dass wir
nicht zu stark greifen wenn es ein
bisschen besser geht wird in der lage
dann müssen wir auch den menschen müssen
wir das stück dieser dieser vorschriften
wieder zurücknehmen und schon kam eine
das gerede von na ja sie kennen die
begrifflichkeit meter genannt worden
sind
ich bin voll der meinung dass wir das
immer wieder neu diskutieren überlegen
müssen abwägen müssen alles ist ein ganz
schwieriger prozess aber so leicht kann
man es ja auch nicht machen dass man
sagt also ja indem man ängste schürt und
sagt da stecken irgendwelche mächte
dahinter oder die wirtschaft profitiert
nur davon dass es ja besucht wir werden
der moment in unseren entscheidungen
nicht durch die wirtschaft geprägt also
war es ein buntes habe ich noch nie
gehört wir werden geprägt wenn überhaupt
dann durch wissenschaft und die
wissenschaftler bestimmen sehr stark
debatte und wir lassen uns sehr sehr
stark davon lenken weil wir in vielen
fällen ja auch nicht eine andere
wissenschaftliche meinungen haben oder
das gegenteil darstellen können also ich
habe nicht gesagt dass die lockdown
maßnahmen von der wirtschaft geprägt
sondern ich habe ganz klar versucht er
eine richtung zu lenken und ich fand das
war nicht früher
und ja und ich möchte mich dagegen
wehren und sagen ich habe gesagt und das
möchten sie mal wieder legen dass die
art der rettungsgelder das wofür geld
bereitgestellt wird und wofür kein geld
bereitgestellt wird ganz stark davon
abhängt wer die einflussreichen
netzwerke und lobbyisten im bundestag
sitzen hat weil ich meine es ist doch
frappierend dass auf der einen seite
sogar unternehmen die dividenden stütz
gelder bekommen haben auf der anderen
seite zum beispiel freiberufler kleine
selbstständige jetzt erstmal bei den
november hilfen überhaupt etwas bekommen
wie ein lebenslauf nichts begründung
auch schon dass gott deswegen finde ich
das ist ganz klar
zur ehrung dieser rettungsgelder ist
nicht am bedarf orientiert sondern sie
hängt davon ab wer hat die starken
lobbys wer hat die staaten
einflussmöglichkeiten und das ist eben
ein großes problem das empfinden ja auch
die menschen fühlen sie sich im stich
gelassen
nein nein dass es das relativ absurd
wirklich absurd schauen sich machen wie
viele arbeitsplätze ohren großen
unternehmen hängen und wie viel
arbeitsplätze an kleinunternehmen so
einfach geht das nicht wie sie es doch
wahrscheinlich fertig mal die
arbeitsplätze gesichert bei der
lufthansa die werfen leute auf die
strasse diesen 60 jahre alt die haben
überhaupt keine chance mehr
das heißt dieses unternehmen macht jetzt
einen radikalen spaß machen sie dieses
muss kreativer draußen einzelnen erleben
und sie machen jetzt seien diese
berühmte unternehmer stellte klar ich
glaube die situation in der wir uns
jetzt befinden ist nachdem sich
wahrscheinlich viele in unserem land so
ein bisschen in dem gefühl eingerichtet
haben im frühsommer das ist eigentlich
keiner besser gemacht hat als wir es
gemacht haben dass wir eigentlich das
schlimmste hinter uns haben wir jetzt in
eine phase gekommen sind die auch die
allermeisten in der politik so nicht
erwartet haben nämlich dass es eine
zweite welle gibt und dass diese zweite
welle sehr viel heftiger ist überall in
europa als das zunächst vermutet worden
ist
ich finde die zeit in jeder form von
relativierungen sind bei fast 500 toten
am tag vorbei in den usa sind wir jetzt
bei fast 3000 oder über 3000 toten heute
sogar an einem tag dass es an einem tag
die opferzahl des 11 september 2001 der
neu gewählte amerikanische präsident joe
biden bereitet seine landsleute auf eine
weitere viertelmillion tot bevor das ist
die situation
gleichzeitig haben wir licht am ende des
tunnels ohne zu wissen wie lange der
tunnel jetzt eigentlich noch genau sein
wird mit hilfe eines impfstoffs und wir
werden versuchen müssen mit sagen wir
mal der größtmöglichen vernunft durch
diese schwierige zeit die noch vor uns
liegt hindurch zu navi
ich glaube der wichtigste satz in dieser
zeit eigentlich für jeden politiker und
jede politikerin übrigens auch für
unseren berufsstand ist der satz ich
weiß es so genau auch nicht fehler
irrtümer fehleinschätzungen werden in
dieser schwierigen zeit die ohne jedes
beispiel sind auch weiter dazu gehören
das höre ich zugegebener von ihrer
partei irgendwie so selten ich gebe zu
irgendwie ich weiß es nicht wird es
irgendwie bei twitter irgendwie nie zu
einem der trending topics schaffen
populisten sind glaube ich auch nicht
wirklich gut darin sondern in aller
regel verfolgen sie das ziel auf
schwierigsten fragen den eindruck zu
erwecken als täten ist eine ganz
einfache antwort aber ich glaube das was
wir für die kommenden wochen und monate
wirklich brauchen werden ist diese durch
diese schwierige zeit die vor uns liegt
hindurch zu kommen dann wird es noch
eine ganz lange phase geben in der wir
sehr intensiv darüber reden werden was
richtig gewesen ist was falsch gewesen
etwas angemessen was unangemessen
gewesen ist und ich glaube wir werden
auf vieles stoßen was falsch gemacht
worden ist
aber ich glaube jetzt geht es erstmal um
die vor uns liegenden monate die hacker
habe ich schon zitiert